i got a really great email from a viewer
named wade who said
kovid has taken away our ability to
behave and i think
it goes much further there seems to be
almost like a covid induced psychosis
that is plaguing this country and some
other parts of the world and i want to
go through it today
i already discussed on yesterday's bonus
show that a number of
unruly passengers on airplanes are being
reported to the faa
that number is increasing dramatically
and much of it is related to or it's
triggered by masks people angry about
someone else
wearing a mask people angry about
someone else not wearing a mask
masks and just getting back to being in
close quarters with people on airplanes
is causing many unruly passengers we
talked about that yesterday
but as wade wrote to me he said quote as
more and more people attend events and
begin to travel
there's an increasing level of violence
and frustration that on the surface
might seem to result
of not having to practice decorum and
civility
in similar situations for the past year
due to the pandemic
i think there's something to this one
category
fan behavior at sporting events in
washington dc
fans fan runs on to court during
washington wizards game four
in latest active misbehavior games just
started and there's a rash of this the
76ers
knicks and jazz have had to ban
fans following playoff game incidents
involving players
then it grew more and now five nba
venues
have banned fans for disrespectful
behavior
during games and it's not just happening
in basketball and it's not just
happening in the u.s
in glasgow scotland fans
of the rangers football club went nuts
thousands of them defying coveted
warnings against large gatherings
getting together in george square to
celebrate the rangers winning their
first
scottish premiership championship in 10
years
the square was just strewn with broken
bottles and bags and
there were flares launched and all sorts
of stuff
riot police came out and then lastly on
the sports front
maskless razorbacks fans in arkansas
led to a bunch of arrests and charges
one such fan
pleaded guilty to violating the face
coverings rule
then we have all of the airline stuff a
report from cnbc
explaining that a flight attendant union
chief says unruly behavior from plane
passengers has never been this bad
we mentioned yesterday that a southwest
airlines passenger punched out a flight
attendant's teeth last week i believe
two teeth
it's actually so bad that american
airlines is extending their suspension
of alcohol service because they believe
the alcohol
can be an aggravating factor yeah it can
and then the road rage has just exploded
some examples include a rash of road
rage incidents in north carolina
in los angeles in colorado in atlanta
i don't believe this is as simple as
people have gotten used to not having to
behave
because they've been home for a year
plus and now they're around
people and they forgot how to behave
that just doesn't strike me as the
explanation
some of this is that there are people
who just no longer care about decorum
some are furious about the pandemic and
about shutdowns
and instead of just being glad to be
back to doing things they're going nuts
and they're taking their fury out on
others
for other people there's just the
difficulty of reintegrating after being
as many people were and continue to be
so scared to do anything and there's a
sort of ptsd taking place
it's coming out in some weird ways for
other people
i think the becoming unaccustomed to
being in groups
has created a sort of agoraphobia and
some people
stay home as a result of it others just
kind of
feel stressed when they go out and then
you have people who are reacting by
lashing out in some of these weird ways
i think this is going to continue for
some time
we've not even we're only starting to
see the resumption and travel
we're seeing oh but let me mention one
other thing
um commuting is horrible psychologically
people who have long commutes it's just
a real drag
on quality of life we know this from
study after study
not having to commute for so long for
many people
and then being dropped back into a
commute as traffic is starting to build
again
um i can only imagine that that's having
a real impact on a lot of people's
psychological state it took months to
adjust
to what was a new reality during the
pandemic
i think it's going to take at least a
few months to adjust
to getting out of it if indeed we
continue to get out of it and hopefully
we will as vaccination continue but i
don't think that there's
any easy solution to this let me know
what you think
and we'll have more on this on our
instagram
where you can find us at david pakman
show
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wrist watch is the
perfect way
to elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing my
ventura watch
on the show mine is the gunmetal vessel
model i'm a big fan of the metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over 26
000 five-star reviews and they stand
behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman